foreign
so I have a theory and I don't know what
to call this or if I should name it or
anything but here's my theory so the
really impressive part about artificial
intelligence is that as it gets better
and better it feels more and more like
human intelligence right which is why we
use that word to the point where it can
actually pass for human intelligence in
some cases like it passes tests it
solves problems it finds patterns it
mimics things and so it can actually
kind of fool you into thinking it's
intelligent and so now we have this
generative AI that can be trained on
massive data sets and spit out unique
outputs that are increasingly impressive
now to be clear AI like artificial
intelligences that have been better at
humans at some things that's been around
for a while like that was kind of the
point actually they could comb through
large amounts of data and find patterns
that humans never would like literally
detect disease in its earliest stage of
development better than an actual doctor
so AI has already been useful
but where it's generative AI that we're
talking about where we're asking AI to
be creative and come up with new things
new text new images new sounds that's
what I'm talking about that's the scary
one so my theory my theory is there are
two levels of success of efficiently
Advanced AI
the first level is when AI generated
content fools you because you weren't
paying attention to AI or like looking
for AI so maybe you like me saw the pope
photo on your timeline a couple days ago
and like just kept scrolling you just
thought oh that's a weird picture of the
Pope kind of a cool jacket I guess but
only when you get told that it's Ai and
not a real picture does it trigger your
skeptical eye and suddenly you're like
oh that's obviously not a real picture
there's so many things wrong the hands
look weird the details are garbled of
course it's a fake picture
but the second level of AI generated
content fooling you is when you know
you're supposed to be looking at AI
and it still fools you that's when it
gets scary
so we've had a couple examples of the
like level one instances like the pope
photo like I mentioned there have been
others floating around like there was
one of like Trump getting arrested even
though he didn't but what's level two
I got an email a couple weeks ago from
an artist you may be familiar with Mr
Jay Maderos wanna have Alta and veinsil
and they had a new track that they were
working on which was a collab where he
wraps alongside Jay-Z
except the Jay-Z voice is not real
it's AI generated
and they were going back and forth on
like how to release this whether or not
they should release it at all like I
want you to listen to this like not the
whole thing I'll play a little bit of it
for you you should still go to the
source and absolutely watch the original
video I'll link it below but I just
needed to hear this and feel what I felt
when I first heard this song
[Music]
they can never become what they aspire
to born in a cell with no one who can
inspire you your hazard was never as
high as it was a lie to you pretending
that they live in the sky lying behind
your roof shooting hoes up at your
ceiling so for those of you who know
what Jay-Z sounds like
that was absurd like that sounded a lot
like Jay-Z to the point where even
knowing that I'm listening to AI
generated content I can still hear it
and sort of enjoy it like I'm actually
listening to Jay-Z
it's a lot now to be clear Mr Jamie
Jones told me they wrote those lyrics
before the AI tools became available and
the tools I used weren't even Plug and
Play Perfect like there were still lots
of layers to it tweaking things
experimenting with different methods
apparently words like feeling and
sealing and appealing were like hard to
get it to rhyme because they'd
pronounced it slightly differently so
they ran it through a bunch of times but
the fact that it's still so good in the
final result that's what opens up the
can of worms it's kind of borderline
scary knowing how good it actually is
just knowing that I'm listening to Ai
and still enjoying it like it's Bars by
Jay-Z and the cherry on top
is that this is the worst this
technology will ever be so there's
examples of level one everywhere like
low stakes content where it passes
because the audience isn't really
looking for AI and it doesn't really
matter like it's true of a lot of the
chatbot stuff too like Chachi PT
and Bard and all the others like Bing
they might write an email you might read
an email that seems pretty sincere but
turns out most of it was written by one
of those chat Bots and it's kind of fine
because it's just an email but just keep
in mind that
the goal of all of these Technologies
is to advance to get to level two like
the goal of the chat bot eventually when
it gets better is to be able to pass as
a human in conversation what does that
mean and the goal of the the image
generator is to be able to produce
usable paintings or drawings or whatever
like a human what does that mean the
goal of self-driving cars is to drive
alongside other humans on the road and
that's wild
but that's that's what they're all
working towards
so is there a solution to this
I mean the answer really is not yet it's
so new that there is no answer some
people think regulation some people
think uh just outright Banning it is an
option I don't really believe in that
but I think what's going to have to
happen is there probably has to be some
sort of a parallel development of tools
that are specifically designed to detect
AI content so that you need to learn to
deploy those tools when there's a reason
to detect AI but
for now
let's enjoy level one
because you won't have just that for
much longer
thanks for watching
catch you in the next one peace
Savage